Aaron Carter's twin sister Angel is
paying tribute to her brother after his
tragic death in an Instagram post Angel
shared a heartfelt message writing quote
to my twin I loved you beyond measure
you will be missed dearly my funny sweet
Aaron I have so many memories of you and
I and I promise to cherish them I know
you're at peace now I will carry you
with me until the day I die and get to
see you again
[Music]
I love making music it's definitely my
happy place Aaron who shot to fame with
his music career in the late 90s was
found dead on Saturday at his home in
California just outside of Los Angeles
with Aaron's manager Taylor helgeson
confirming his death to ET following the
news Aaron was 34 an official cause of
death has not yet been revealed
the last few years haven't been easy for
Aaron and his family what I need is
people to
understand that I'm human and I make
mistakes just like every other human in
this world after going public about his
issues with mental health in 2019 Angel
and their older brother Nick filed a
restraining order against Aaron leading
to a rift between the siblings Aaron
loves his family very much and that's
where his heart is at and that's where
he's coming from he's coming from Love
and he's just wanting to see it return
despite their many highs and lows Nick
too shared a tribute for his baby
brother the 42 year old Backstreet Boys
singer wrote in part quote my heart is
broken even though my brother and I have
had a complicated relationship my love
for him has never ever faded sometimes
we want to blame someone or something
for a loss but the truth is that
addiction and mental illness is the real
villain here I will miss my brother more
than anyone will ever know I love you
chis now you can finally have the piece
you can never find here on Earth he says
if you're ever in trouble just call me
and I'll tell you and I'll guide you
through and talk to you about it and you
know because he's been through all that
kind of stuff amid his trained
relationship with his older brother Nick
he shared this touching message while
sitting down with E.T in 2017. if Nick
is watching this right now what would
you want to say to Nick he could just
look in that camera right there what
would you say I will always love you and
and I will always have forgiveness in my
heart for you
[Music]
foreign